all the viewers know you've got you'd be
uh regarding to Islam and everything
obviously I know yeah video went viral
but um how's your life changing anyway
how do you feel I mean it's been a bit
of a while now yeah you feel I've
changed you feel a bit relaxed yeah the
Brotherhood is amazing yeah that's the
first thing I will say you want to cure
racism Islam curious racism like it's
it's amazing the Brotherhood that's
that's certainly there I certainly do
feel more relaxed I feel like uh I
always had Faith to a degree so it's not
like I'm brand new to the idea of Faith
but I certainly feel more relaxed I feel
like a lot of the things which I knew
were degenerate but especially when
you're you kind of get to a weird Fame
was a weird thing to also to answer your
question when you're kind of on your way
up to fame or you're getting famous or
you're quite famous you want to be in
the place you're supposed to be right
and then you get to a level of Fame
where you just don't want to go anywhere
it's just like but a lot of things it's
great to look at things that previously
I would have felt like for work I should
be at or
for social because people I know I
should be at and just just go around
no staying home so uh that's good
um what's the hardest thing so
things and hard I've got alcohol that
hasn't been difficult yeah but I've
always had insane willpower so I can I
can do anything I wanted I just feel
like it's a journey there's a lot to
learn it can be quite daunting you know
like even the even the language even
area it's like it's very hard to learn
so I'm just on a journey like everyone
else that I'm trying to study so so give
us some Arabic words
all I know so far is Alaska it's the
easiest word
but yeah it's very hard so I'm doing my
best with it but uh
I think like I've explained before on
other podcasts it's the only religion
that that's left on the planet worth
that has serious boundaries I saw
actually um Islamic guy an Islamic
podcast I don't know who he was who said
Tate reverted to Islam because it's
intolerant or because its degree of
intolerance is because of its strict
lines and people are trying to walk away
from it because of its strict lines but
Tate understands the beauty of strict
lines and that's exactly what it is you
need to have boundaries in life like
everything we just discussed if you
remove boundaries it becomes a
free-for-all right so you need to have
mountains well that's a very good point
he made because I've not seen that I
like to watch that because as a young I
speak to guys about Islam all the time
and young boys and I see them trying to
chase that Western kind of way of life I
want to be this that when you've all got
who has it all in this world like you
say yeah he comes to Islam so to all you
young guys feel ashamed like yeah don't
feel shy or embarrassed to be what you
are a Muslim I'd be proud I've always
been uh I could be in a meeting anyway
everyone knows me I won't touch alcohol
I'll pray in the corner brothers and
sisters the same way we're going to have
to check out of a hotel if we're staying
at one and the same way we plan for our
trips here we gotta plan in for a trip
more important to the Hereafter and what
better way of planning and Investing For
Your Hereafter for your gender brothers
and sisters and investing in the dean
center help us to establish the first
mega dawa Center in America with four
acres five buildings 35
000 square foot property we're very
close to reaching our goal go ahead
click the link below donate right now
may God Almighty Allah reward all of you
[Music]
thank you